good evening
it is such a blessing to to work at the
harlem children's zone
an african-american-led organization
that has pioneered the field
of comprehensive place-based services
from cradle to career
and that word comprehensive is so key to
what we do
you know most interventions focus on one
piece of a complicated giant puzzle
but that's not enough to solve the
puzzle you don't solve education
without understanding the home context
of the home environment of a young
scholar
or the broader context of health
nutrition or criminal justice
the unit of change for us is not the
individual child
it's the entire neighborhood you have to
do multiple things
at the same time and we have 20 years of
data
to prove that this works we've had 7 000
graduates of our baby college
we've eliminated the black white
achievement gap in our schools
we've reduced obesity rates in our
health programs
and have close to 1 000 students
enrolled in college
we weave together a net of services so
tightly so that no one will fall through
the cracks
and we've inspired global practitioners
we've had over 500 plus communities
across the u.s
and 70 plus countries come and visit us
to learn our model
you see the the problems of the globe
and the problems of the world
are not neatly siloed into buckets
so therefore the solutions must be
comprehensive they must be holistic
and now we're in the midst of a global
pandemic
covert 19 has revealed to us what we
always knew to be true
the poorest among us pay the highest
price with their lives and their
livelihood
and that's playing out every day in the
african-american community
where we're 3.6 times more likely to die
of covet than our white counterparts
we're seeing those health disparities on
the ground in new york city our nation's
epicenter
and to compound the impact of the health
disparities there's significant economic
devastation
where one in four of our families in
harlem report food insecurity
and 57 report a loss of income
or a loss of their job but to
to better understand the work of the
harlem children's zone i want to share a
story with you
about a second grade scholar named sean
sean is a beautiful black boy whose
smile would light
up any room that he's in and when
quarantine began in march
we noticed that sean wasn't attending
virtual school
and after some investigation we've come
to learn
that sean's mom was hospitalized due to
covet so he was at home
with grandma and his baby sibling who
was his only viable support system
since sean's father is incarcerated
grandma was struggling
there wasn't much food in the household
limited diapers
and sean didn't even have a computer
when mom was released from the hospital
their challenges deepened
because they could no longer stay with
grandma due to her pre-existing health
conditions
so sean his baby sibling and his mom had
to go to a shelter
sean's story is not atypical at the
harlem children's zone
we know sean and millions like him all
across the country deserve to have
everything that this world has to offer
without any quality
robbing them of that opportunity all the
result of racism
and historical and systemic
underinvestment and now
compounded by covert 19.
our comprehensive model uniquely
positions the harlem children's zone in
the fight of kovit
the success that we have on the ground
in harlem makes it imperative
and it is our responsibility to share
what we know works
with the country we have developed a
comprehensive covert 19 relief and
recovery
response for our community that was
surfaced from our community
focused on five primary areas of need
and already servicing families like
shant
they are the following one emergency
relief funds
we know that our families need cash in
their hands right now
two protecting our most vulnerable we
know our families need
access to essential goods and
information so that is food
that's mass that's curated resourceless
and public health
campaigns three bridging the digital
divide
we believe that internet is a
fundamental right so we need to ensure
our families have connectivity and also
all school-age children in the household
have the proper learning devices four
zero learning laws we know that there is
a generation of students at risk
of losing an entire year of their
education we need to make sure that we
are providing high quality
virtual programming in addition to
having safe re-entry plans
for school re-entry and five
mitigating the mental health crisis
there's a generation at risk of having
ptsd
due to the massive amounts of toxic
stress we need to ensure that our
families have access to telehealth
and other virtual response supports
we have six amazing partners across six
cities in the united states
that are adopting our model for their
own context in their community
they are oakland minneapolis chicago
detroit newark and atlanta
in addition to those partners we have
three national partners
who will be sharing our model and
sharing our strategies through their
network
in addition to amplifying our impact by
policy advocacy
we will have impact on three levels
individual impact on the ground in
harlem
across a number of outcomes in education
in health and economics
reaching 30 000 people this community
level impact
across six cities again through our
amazing partners
that will reach an additional seventy
thousand people
and then national impact not only
through policy advocacy
but through capacity building at scale
our answer to covet 19 the despair and
inequities plagued in our communities
is targeting neighborhoods with
comprehensive services
we have certainly not lost hope and we
invite you to join us on the front lines
of this war
thank you
[Music]